Okay. So I do want to start today with this
story of Donald Trump telling, uh, this group
of progressive. So
first year members of Congress to go back
to their original countries. This is something
he tweeted over the weekend. It's been getting
a ton of attention, but I want to do it right.
And I don't want to do just the Hahaha stupid
Trump. He doesn't realize that Puerto Rico
is part of the United States thing because
there's actually a lot to say here. And a
lot of it is, is not actually being said.
And I think that some important points are
being missed. So first of all, the facts,
uh, Donald Trump lost it on Twitter yesterday.
He sent out this series of tweets directed
at this group of first term of female democratic
members of the house. This includes presumably
Alexandria Casteo, Cortez Ilhan, Omar, uh,
Rashida to leave Aiyana Presley here from
Boston is sort of presumed or believed to
be part of this group. And of course, uh,
AOC is American.
Uh, Ilana Omar was born in Somalia, came to
the United States, is a, an American citizen.
Um, Ayana Presley's from the u s Rashida to
leave is from the United States. And um, we,
uh, we'll look immediately at the tweets that
Donald Trump sent out. Quote. So interesting
to see quote, Progressive Democrat Congress
women who originally came from countries whose
governments are a complete and total catastrophe,
the worst, most corrupt and inept to anywhere
in the world. If they even have a functioning
government at all now loudly and viciously
telling the people of the United States the
greatest and most powerful nation on earth,
how our government is to be run, why don't
they go back and help fix the totally broken
and crime infested places from which they
came. Then come back and show us how it's
done. These places need your help badly. You
can't leave fast enough. I'm sure that Nancy
Pelosi would be very happy to quickly work
out free travel arrangements.
So the obvious immediate reflexive response
is, hold on a second. They're mostly Americans.
What's Trump talking about? Their original
countries to Ilana Omar immigrated to the
u s from Somalia, but as an American citizen.
Otherwise we're talking about Americans here
now. If you mean the countries that their
ancestors came from, then it actually gets
even stupider because everyone came from somewhere
else in the u s other than native Americans.
And even they, you go back far enough came
from Africa, depending on how far back you
go. Alexandria Ocasio Cortez is Puerto Rican
by origin, which is part of the United States.
Another point of confusion that Donald Trump
can't seem to understand, so this is dripping
with xenophobia. Some are calling it racism.
Immediately. Semantic Games start about what
is racism? What does that really mean? Uh,
your mind reading what Donald, what's in Donald
Trump's head? I don't want to get into that.
We're actually going to deal with that separately.
Maybe tomorrow or Wednesday. AOC is more American
than Trump, or at least as an American in
that Trump's grandfather came from Germany,
Germany. Germany is definitely not the United
States. AOC, his grandparents, I believe,
came to New York from Puerto Rico, which is
part of the United States, but I actually
don't think this is the right focus. I believe
that the correct focus here has to be to call
out and not fall for Donald Trump's ploy to
foment division on the left and to distract
from all of the crises and failures in which
he's involved. Some of which I'm going to
tell you about a little bit later. Yeah, there
are serious things to figure out about the
direction of the Democratic Party. Nancy Pelosi
is to the right of the party. Some of these
new members want to pull the party to the
left.
You don't have to agree with everything that
these new members represent. It's fine and
healthy to disagree on issues, but this is
Donald Trump trying to rile people up on the
left. Trump has chosen to pick the Pelosi
side in the Polosi versus new progressive
dems quote fight, which is a fight mostly
being fomented by people who, who would benefit
from the Democratic Party being divided. This
isn't surprising, but we really shouldn't
fall for this stuff. So number one, recognize
the pattern. Donald Trump creates a controversy,
then backs off of it and moves on after successfully
distracting from things he doesn't want. The
new cycle focusing on, or version two of this
is Donald Trump creates a problem and then
claims to have solved the problem. Okay. We've
seen this a bunch of times. Trump called off
an attack on Iran. Well, yeah, but he called
for the attack attack first and authorized
it.
And then he called it off when he supposedly
got more information about the number of civilians
that were going to be killed. Uh, Trump, you
know, created a problem with Iran by bailing
on the Iran nuclear deal. And now he says
he's going to fix it and he's open to a new
deal. Well, we wouldn't be in this situation
if he didn't cause the problem in the first
place. So this is Trump's a sort of pattern,
his emo, and in this case, mere participation
in the dumb pissing matches that Trump generates
means that we lose. So that's, that's a really
important to understand. Now, more importantly,
there's another theme. Trump is playing the
role of Russia with the Democratic Party by
picking aside in order to divide us, okay?
So understand this, the Trump tweets are crazy,
but Trump is trying to divide the left for
his benefit by taking a side in Pelosi versus
new progressive's.
AOC is American telling her to go back to
her country as ignorance, you know, phobia,
but don't fall for it because in the same
way that Russia's goal and meddling with foreign
countries, internal politics, it goes beyond
the United States of course. But just using
the u s and example, it's not that Trump is
beloved by Russia or whatever. Russia figured
out that Trump would be extremely divisive
for the country and that's why they wanted
to help them. In the same way Donald Trump
knows that taking a side in Pelosi versus
new Progressive Democrats is potentially going
to divide the Democratic Party, arguably to
his advantage. So the takeaway has to be,
we have 16 months left until the election.
We have the numbers. Most Americans are disgusted
by this type of crap, so let's not allow Donald
Trump to play these games and further divide
us and let's not let stupidity distract us
from the actual and real scandals that are
going on.
For example, the connection between Donald
Trump and rapist Jeffrey Epstein every day
that the headlines are Trump tweets about,
go back to your countries instead of the headlines
being Trump is accused of rape by one of the
same people that accused Jeffrey Epstein of
rape. That is a win for Donald Trump, and
you can't ever forget about the fact that
there is a constant distract the thun going
on either consciously or unconsciously. Just
don't take the bay. Don't fall for it. Okay?
W really important that we not fall into the
same circles that have succeeded, uh, in helping
Donald Trump distract from really serious
problems that are going on many, many
times over the last two and
a half years.